look you said that you're looking at all
the different religions yeah once again
you said you don't accept idolatry and
stuff I accept accept I believe in that
as well I agree with you look the first
thing I want to say to you is from a
Muslim perspective from an Islamic
perspective yeah is that we would say
the starting point for us is a very
strict monotheism yeah so for us and the
sign point is like a monotheism well we
believe that there is an ultimate
creator sustainer an ultimate power
that initiated the universe if that
makes sense now how feasible does that
sound oh my Russia was at the sound of
your mind yeah I believe that the
Creator is what brings life to the
material realm Arturo is this an
illusion
yeah we can't take any of this stuff
with us when we go so the idea of an
immortal God from which we all
originated gives us purpose so you agree
with that idea you accept it I mean do
you believe in it their creator yeah
mate it its life to existence yeah it's
different in a create and creationism
creationism you're saying you reject
kind of like the biblical narrative by
at the same time you don't reject the
idea of an all-knowing all-powerful
creator force that side of the universe
yeah okay it's all right so what I was
going to say now since that's the case
now we have to define some of the
attributes of this creator yeah would
you accept that some of the attributes
are creative capacity or power or
knowledge would you say that these are
fundamental to - such as creativity
yes it is yeah you're saying is creative
the creative essence of the universe and
of individual souls yeah yes god I
completely agree how can we out your
intuition for example it is a
fundamental metaphysical function of our
of our personality our soul how come you
know how can we we can't prove we can't
program a machine for example to do
these things so how can we ever prove
that this is I exist outside yeah it's
good all right so having said that I
want ask your question what's the most
appropriate relationship you can have
with such an entity the most appropriate
relationship is one harmony essentially
when you live in harmony with mankind
and with the planet you are living in
harmony with God there is no separation
between the effects that you enact upon
the world and what comes to you what
more moral consequences okay I accept
that to a certain extent let me show you
something we have our own version of
that right so we say because if you look
at these in traditions they do reference
how to be one with God and these kinds
of things from our perspective we say
there is a way to basically be
harmonious with the will of the creator
and the way that works is basically the
Creator has made things created the
creation and in the creation you have
anima an inanimate right
as for the inanimate objects around us
they are forcibly or obliged to kind of
submit to the will of the of the Creator
right so basically in other words in
order to be one with creation in that
sense not in the sense of actual
physicality but we're talking in that
figurative sense the way to do that
would be to do where everything else
around you is doing so everything around
us if you accept the premise of them an
all-powerful creator is submissive to
that creator we will say by extension it
makes sense to also be submissive to the
Creator in the same way that everything
being submissive see does that make
sense I completely agree yeah submissive
to you but we know will of the creator
exactly the will of the creator
but never to an authoritarian figure
that's why I'm so against idolatry
because anyone these false prophets or
these dogmatic beliefs these are these
are not following these are not
creations of gods but their creations of
human beings and so never listen to a
boss or something that doesn't agree
with your own sense of morality that
comes from within but live in harmony
with with that that intuition which
comes essentially from God all right so
let me ask you a question because the
thing is it becomes very subjective when
it becomes clouded and that kind of
terminology I'll be honest with you
because what we will say is that if our
essentially our aim in life is to be
submissive to God right in the sense of
the aforementioned if that's the the aim
of life for the purpose of life surely
there should be a uniform way a
universal way that God has allowed human
beings to be able to do that a uniform I
agree yeah so now there we would say
this is the Islamic narrative I've been
completely straightforward with you yeah
the Islamic narrative is that the way
that happens is that the creator
communicates with the creation and he
does so through prophets who have come a
full time yeah so prophets are a
necessary extension of what is necessary
to happen on appropriate between the
creator and the creation or in this case
human being specifically who are
sentient beings and able to make their
own decisions on free world creatures so
there was a need for prophets there was
a need for the communication between the
creator and the creation and so prophets
came up for time the Islamic narrative
is that so long as humans were on earth
there were prophets preaching the
message of what we'd call submission
yeah so people like Adam you might have
heard of these kind of biblical names
Adam and Noah and Moses and Jesus all of
those are prophets that came to their
respective peoples and their respective
times and preached the message of
submission to their peoples
does that make sense right so what we
would say is that the the messengers
came fundamentally with two different
things they came with a message and they
came with a an evidence base to
substantiate that message so in the in
the case of Moses you might have heard
of these stories or basically you know
the C splitting and all these kind of
different things yeah it's in the Old
Testament it's also on the forum these
stories are meant to indicate that these
these are evidences yeah that are used
to prove the message of submission
because there's something which break
the natural capacity of physical reality
around us so there are evidence that
basically God is the author of of the
message that these prophets come with
now whereas all of the prophets and
messengers were sent to their respective
owners
yes this is this see spitting why is
that
I mean why why does that give evidence
that this is otherwise what's that got
to do with Mohammed first off disease
right so not the C splitting doesn't
have anything to do specifically with
Muhammad's message but it's I mean
although it is no Quran we're talking
specifically about Moses so in his time
and this is an interesting thing that
the rush to be alluded to by some of our
scholars in Islam that depending on the
societal kind of what society popular at
the time the evidence base that the
messengers come with suits that so at
the time of kind of what is it the
younger what you call it the middle
Empire whether whoever is in Egypt when
ramesses ii was there and they say that
Ramesses is linked to Pharaoh or no
let's mention the back at this time they
were fascinated with magic magic and all
those kind of things now Moses came with
a you could call it a miracle really
which basically broke the rules of
physical nature yeah and which which
acted as an evidence for the for his
people so when people saw it they said
okay well this makes sense you I'm
saying alright so for us now you will
say was our miracle right because we
need some evidence as well to be able to
substantiate the claim that prophet
Muhammad is the final messenger because
that's our claim
our claim is that prophet muhammad
whereas all of the other prophets were
sent to their people in their times
jesus moses etc Abram Muhammad was sent
for all peoples in all times so that's
the Islamic narrative so here's what
he's come with as he's come with an
auditory miracle or auditory evidence
base whereas all the prophets came
before usually with a visual evidence
base so like for example in the case of
Moses the sea splitting was something
for human beings to visualize and see
whereas what we say is the evidence base
for the Islamic message is actually the
Quran itself which is something actually
which was transmitted orally although it
does have of course written books as
well to cooperate and triangulate the
veracity of the oral message so here
the Quran has many different things
within it which basically would lead
someone to believe that it couldn't have
been because you were saying use a kind
of like rationalistic approach we're
using a probe ballistic kind of rush
nursing approach you would I would argue
that the Quranic discourse contains
within it an evidence base I'm actually
not a rationalist I'm an imperious okay
so yeah Russian isn't it oh yeah I think
I got me something yeah yeah we can't
just rush it
we need to experience - fair enough I
think you're right about that as well
and that's why by the way the
fundamental thing in Islam is as follows
one of the one of the fundamental
messages Islam comes with is as follows
well as Christianity says we're born
with original sin yeah
aslam says no we're born with something
called the filter the filter ax is a
predisposition to to basically submit to
God not only to know who he is that the
higher power but to submit to him
automatically so this presupposition is
awakened by the various messages or the
various evidences that human being is
there thereafter exposed to so human
being is for example exposed to the the
fine-tuning of the universe and you
don't have to be a physicist to read to
appreciate the fine-tuning of the
universe
you can literally look with your naked
eye and the fact that the universe is in
fact finely tuned right and these kind
of things
aim to reawaken you
beings from the sale of slumber into and
the recollection of God so that's the
main thing of the Islamic message as
with the Quranic discourse as we've said
before has within it evidences we would
say which are very powerful in
convincing people that this is a
basically something which had to be
extra human in other words it couldn't
have been put together by a human
ability so we were saying for example
the fact that the Quran precisely
discusses events that happens in the
future and I'll give you one example of
that there at a time of the Prophet
there were the Romans and a Persians and
the Quran makes very specific
predictions about who will win wars and
the case of chapter 30 verse 1 to 6 it
talks about the Romans decisively going
to beat the the Persians in three to
nine years in a nearby land now these
are this is one of many different
predictions of the future the Quran
makes and that the Sun now which is the
secondary book of the corpus that
Muslims believe in or the hadith the
strong hadith make of the future from a
probabilistic perspective we can say ok
well probably if someone says one thing
or two things they might have guessed
him to be correct but if we put them all
together it becomes very very difficult
to make the argument that he guessed all
of those correct especially when we
consider by the way did you know let me
tell you something in Jehovah's Witness
in the in the in the church of the
jehovah's witness you know they
predicted and by the way they believed
in this kind of thing where people will
bring you know divinely inspired they
predicted that the day of judgment will
be on 90 in the year 1977 you know that
and when that year did not when the day
of judgment didn't happen in that year
they cool there the great disappointment
because i mean i don't know why anyone
would be disappointed for the live
judgment not happening but they called
it the great disappointment the reason
why is because the prediction didn't
materialize and that has repercussions
around vacations for the message because
it couldn't bring divine if it didn't
materialize because it was meant to me
from all-knowing sauce
the saying the Quran predicted the
Romans were gonna defeat the Persians
the Roman Empire fell out for are you
talking about the Holy Roman to the
first of all the two Roman empires right
so the Roman Empire started in the year
31 BC yeah
the gal the Gallic Wars and stuff like
that whatever and it continued on
but then the Holy Roman Empire side okay
now the Byzantine Empire which was what
was around at the time of the Prophet
Mohammed and continued on to Matilda at
1400s this is what we refer to yeah okay
but the Roman Empire as you would have
known from the history lesson that you
know them were in constant wars with the
sassanids empires or they also called
the Sicilians emphasis Aeneas not others
yeah basically they put the persians and
then and this was referred to in the
western history books as the roman
sassanid wars now the point is the roman
empire as you would have known from from
the year 400 onwards and the profit came
around six hundred thirty you know
around that time so from the seventh
century but from that year from that
time period it was going down there was
a degeneration of the Roman Empire
anyways and so the Sassanid Empire was
much stronger so wonderful I made the
claim that the Roman Empire was going to
beat the Sassanid Empire in three to
nine years and in a pile and all these
different things it wasn't it was a kind
of ridiculous claim if you think about
from a probability perspective it's the
equivalent of betting on a very low team
maybe in the Champions League being a
very high team may be in the top five in
the in the Premier League right
I'm betting that they will beat them in
a certain way in a certain place in a
certain time period all these different
things so probabilistically the odds are
very low for that and that's one example
but there are many different examples
for example the conquest of Arabia by
the Muslims the fact that other nations
who fall into the hands of the Muslims
like Egypt and Yemen in Syria and Jordan
you know and Pakistan and India it's in
dual hand they're all these different
places which are now part of the rope
the the Islamic empire have been
predicted to be conquered by the by
Muslim hands by basically so all of this
is when we put this into a probability
generator it becomes very difficult to
argue that cook this all could have been
guests and I would actually argue I make
a very daring claim here
this is this kind of frequency and
accuracy of predictions has never been
able has never been predicted by anyone
I don't know if any human being if you
want to bring Nostradamus or the the job
is when there's anyone that you wanna
that have made predictions of the future
with this many with this much frequency
and detail which have actually
materialized in the way that they've
been to realized do you see what I'm
saying
so here when we say we have evidence for
the veracity and the truthfulness of
Islam we're not just saying that we have
kind of superfluous evidence or kind of
arbitrary subjective type evidences our
evidences are probably our actually can
be analyzed objectively you see what I'm
saying
this is not regarding the fact that the
Quran is also in and of itself a book
that claims that has no contradictions a
book that challenges mankind to produce
a chapter like him a book of the we
would actually I make the argument then
the only religious ancient religious
book ancient religious book which has
been preserved in terms of its its
material its corpus
we've never the Muslims have never had a
controversy and this can go on the
record and believe me I'm here every
week and people try and they'll try and
maybe but I can say this completely
clearly the Muslims have never had a
controversy on what constitutes the
Quran never it's never happened they've
had controversies on everything else but
they've never had a controversy on what
constitutes the Quran the Christians
around the other hand they are differing
on how many how many books on in the
biblical canon the the process say
seventy two books the Catholics say
sorry the Protestants am 66 the
Catholics say 72 the Eastern Orthodox 81
so here your names now how many books
are in the in the Bible let alone the
manuscripts in these things so here what
we're saying is not only deny our
evidences there are analyzable just a
word but also we have that which is
necessary for a book to be a Word of God
a preserved book free from contradiction
and unlimite book so with that you see
the power of the
the the argument yeah no I believe that
it's been like you know you when you buy
a software for the first time and you
install updates yes like Christianity
came along that was one update and we've
had Islam yeah I said that's a good way
the thing is that we the only problem
was yeah yeah in any religion is
violence as you know yes
we've always seen this violence in all
religions I'm not here to blame
yes yeah I think that the only problem
is that the thing that people blame
Islam for there is why they so violent
yeah there is and then they have to kind
of look at themselves were the Western
intervention we also have to say exactly
that area of the world has been a kind
of hodgepodge of different civilizations
like that boy Rome to the west yet the
Mongols Arabs were all competing and and
of course that violence is very harmful
to a person and it causes arguments okay
I accept what you're saying you're right
violence is never a good thing but
that's a in defense of Islam yeah when
people accuse Islamic world to face my
violence yeah look at the cultural
context here yeah exactly I mean if we
look at the raw data you'll find that in
terms of population I would actually
make the argument that it's like Muslim
people as a proportion of the population
are probably the least violent I know
that sounds ridiculous in the last 100
years they have proven to be the least
violent people in the world in terms of
religion why
and this gotta sound ridiculous some
guys laughing the head off in a home
there believe me but if you count the
amount of people that have died as a
result of the imperialistic Wars or
world war one world war two also if you
count the full Wars of America and if we
consider state violence as a kind of
violence which we there's no reason for
us not to we'll come to the conclusion
that the most violent people have been
atheists like Stalin others and
Christians if you consider Hitler or
Christian I don't know why he considered
himself and people like him and so on
and so forth it's not actually for
as reasonably and in the grand scheme of
things as a proportion of the population
especially if we talk about the colonial
period because most of the Muslim world
was subjugated under the colonial or
western wall it fairs actually quite
well but having said that because of the
kind of the post Cold War terroristic
backlash that we've been getting and the
the focus on terrorism so a lot of
people now will think of Islam as a
violent religion but we shouldn't think
just looking at the raw data of Islam as
any more or less violent as of the war
face who have proponents of those days
actually performing more more violence
in the in the span of the last 100 150
years than Muslims but going back to
what I was saying I was saying that look
we have an argument for basically the
the truthfulness of Islam yeah I'm not
gonna lie to you I believed I was going
to be straightforward with you yeah
because I like you you know you're a
nice guy he's dressed well you know I
came here not I didn't even I didn't
even dress properly today you know this
game you know I was gonna I was gonna
come I wasn't gonna come today but I'm
happy I did because I had a conversation
with you yeah listen to me I'm gonna
tell you directly I believe that the
purpose of life is to worship God
through submission not only is that the
case I believe that the guidelines for
human beings is therefore the Quran
because it's the final book for the
reasons I've mentioned so if you want to
live a fruitful life which is in
compliance with the will of God it's got
to be done through the injunctions of
the Quran and the Sunnah now I've given
you the reasons why like I've given you
some more of an epistemological base as
to why we believe in what we believe do
you accept that that epistemological
base I have given you is an argument
which can be accepted or should be
accepted based on the evidences before I
think that unless someone comes up with
a more up-to-date version of truth
the illogic courtroom yes I suppose it
can make sense to accept that as the
most up-to-date fantastic so what we can
do is we can do the Shahadah right now
this adder is the declaration of faith'
now you believe in you believe in what
I've just said you would you agree that
the Quran is probably the Word of God
based on what I've soldiers okay so what
do you do now is you it's good now to
become a Muslim and what the word Muslim
actually means is someone who submits
their will to God as we've said in the
beginning that's the whole point of it
and what I'll do is I'll give you my
number
and then you will discuss more like you
know how to kind of perform your rituals
and these kind of things and get your a
package of things to do in watch and I
will take it easy on you but how do you
feel should go for it and I I wouldn't
call myself not too much already
practicing it's nothing new for me I was
very very much like that yeah would you
like that okay let's do it them so I'm
gonna say an hour but you answer or you
just kind of follow what I say and then
I'll say you in English okay yeah I'll
say never first so follow I say a shadow
yeah I'll say in Arabic and then you say
Ann Arbor and then a English first
yeah okay fine so say a shadow I'll say
that so what you're gonna say is I bear
witness that there's only one God worthy
of worship being submissive to which is
we believe that the God that we cook
yeah and that the Prophet is the final
messenger yeah okay
ash hadu an LA ilaha illallah WA ash
hadu ana muhammadan rasulullah
nice one for the family or friend
so now I'm going to give you my number
off camera a kiss and then you can call
me for anything you need yeah and by the
way we're probably going to get
something to eat afterwards you're
definitely invite today's eat by the way
it's one of the extensions of it so
you're already in a Muslim celebration
all right Yeomans give you my number
I'm very fond of you sorry guys please